rien d'inhabituel ce soir du 5 juillet
un train de la montreal manie atlantique
chargés de pétrole hautement inflammable
traverse le sud du québec menée par un
seul homme
compagnie qui nous a fourni une analyse
qui nous permettait d'évaluer que
c'était possible les femmes la compagnie
east et voit son équipement sont
surveillés par transports canada dernier
rapport a été fait en odeurs on avait
décelé aucune anomalie dans leurs
opérations avant d'aller dormir pour la
nuit en contrebas à lac mégantic le
conducteur les sont très en voix
principale en marche et son surveillance
[Musique]
les règles actuelles ne permettent
madame c'est une pratique qui semble
assez répandue dans l'industrie
une heure plus tard c'est la cata
ok 1
grâce à des courriels des rapports
jamais divulgué enquête lève le voile
sur les dangers l'incompétence les
influences et l'inaction qui ont précédé
la tragédie
on le disait qu'un jour ça voir arriver
il voit arriver de coin ostie
[Musique]
quatre jours depuis qu'un train aveugle
a décimé le centre ville de lac-mégantic
au milieu d'un point de presse impromptu
le grand patron de la montreal maine et
atlantique accuse
[Musique]
la cause de l'accident semble identifiés
et même à désigner le coupable tout le
conducteur est suspendue mais les gens
de lac-mégantic l'ont compris la cause
de l'accident est plus complexe
les décisions prises ce soir là ne
relève pas seulement du conducteur un
avis de transports canada que nous avons
obtenues ces bleus d'importantes
faiblesses au niveau des contrôleurs à
farnham
certains d'entre eux connaissent mal les
règles et sont incapables de les
appliquer mma tarde à agir des blessures
et des dommages sont à prévoir
transports canada a toléré la situation
bien trop longtemps nous a dit cet
employé changeable mari ike uche à la
sauver
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle ceni tourner ce
journaliste alain ackad à radio canada
plusieurs employés en ont gros sur le
coeur mais se sentent tenus au silence
[Musique]
voilà ma compagne m'a menti
à lesparre dès à présent oui twitter
vous lassez madame pour quatre salles
arrive et on est averti doit pas parler
s'était employé est le seul qui a pris
le risque plus sales plus que c'était
dangereux pour la vie du monde et notre
vie à nous aussi
mma dutil a toujours régné sur la
sécurité est le meilleur exemple est le
manque d'entretien
en avril on change des fois des rails
bocoum organique le yari vannes bat la
dre il causait on n'avait pas voulu la
remplacer
on a le chercher dans ce grand prix un
morceau de ré pour faire un boucan pour
nous dépanner les gens marchandent même
tout le temps plusieurs avis aux ordres
sont émis à mma au fil des ans en raison
du mauvais état de sa voie qui traverse
une douzaine de villes du sud du québec
y donne un ministre et avec cette liste
là on était supposé de réparer ce que
transports canada ni donner vie et nous
la donnait on a faisait main paul 8e
maintenant six mois après ils revenaient
ils refaisaient une liste bessard
camarades même transports canada d'après
moi on aurait dit des mots stasi
mais selon moi il y en a quand même
échappé un ballon d'eau chaude
même frustration devant l'inaction de
transports canada à farnham où se trouve
le quartier général des activités de mma
ça arrive et peut-être une fois par
année qu'un wagon échapper tout
simplement puis descendez il travaillait
la rue
lorsque vous voyez lors des wagons à la
dérive en plein coeur de la ville qui
est coupée en deux par la voie ferrée
[Musique]
qui était inspecteur qui vérifie tout il
devrait avoir toutes les règles les
rapports est-ce qu'ils n'ont eu le
rapport
où est-ce qu'ils sont tout simplement
passé un peu à côté de la track excusez
mon expression à lac-mégantic l'état de
la voie n'était un secret pour personne
climie tremblay et rédacteur en chef du
journal local
son bureau est à deux pas de la zone
rouge et de la voie ferrée
tous les signaux d'alarmé qui ont été
envoyés au cours des derniers mois ont
tous traités passés sous silence dans
l'indifférence totale
à peine trois semaines avant la tragédie
un rail en mauvais état a perforé le
réservoir d'une locomotive causant un
déraillement et le déversement de 13
mille litres de diesel à frontenac
cet axe alors oui c'est un signal
d'alarmé très fort et c'est
incompréhensible que de trois semaines
tard et encore des convois de ce tableau
qui empruntent le même chemin de fer
[Musique]
la sécurité c'était plus vérifie si on
avait voulu naître notre chapeau notre
sens le reste la voie d'affichés
pour en savoir plus sur les problèmes
d'entretien de nm1 et sa fiche de
sécurité nous avons obtenu les rapports
d'inspection réalisés dans le maine
nous avons soumis les données à jacques
wenders liane chargé de cours à
l'université du québec un des rares
experts qui a accepté de commenter
c'est une période de 10 ans et là nous
comptons à peu près 7000 600 infractions
réglementaires graff ou faible peu
importe sa science y on tient bien
content ça fait plus ou moins 760 par an
quasiment deux par jour donc là il ya un
état de négligence totale kippen que
constater on ne te graves fissures
l'écartement du rail
l'absence de boulons des aiguilles en
mauvais état
pire et même en effet que peu sa voix et
son matériel et tout indique que la
situation est la même
de ce côté ci de la frontière et on a
tout à fait raison de s'inquiéter
dans les villes et villages qui sont
traversés par se voie ferrée du fait que
oui il y à des convois du 10000 tonnes
qui roule et qui ne sont plus le
sécuritaire l'acquisition de tronçons
abandonné pour les revitaliser est un
peu la marque de commerce des éleveurs
craquent
[Applaudissements]
son prix d'un succès et celui du oui ce
conseil central
mais en 1996 le déraillement d'un train
rempli de propane et de pétrole cause
d'une explosion spectaculaire à wayaux
rigueur les autorités attribuent
l'accident au mauvais entretien des
rails et à la formation inadéquate du
personnel
le passé de npo cats n'a pas échappé à
transports canada
un fonctionnaire écrit à son sujet en
en passant c'est le type du oui ce
conseil central certaines ses traites et
conduit par un seul homme jusqu'à ce que
les syndicats fassent pression pour
l'interdire
ça semble avoir mieux fonctionné pour
lui dans le monde en effet après s'être
fait ordonner de cesser la conduite un
seul homme au wisconsin et brocade va
revenir à la charge
et cette fois beaucoup plus près de chez
nous
[Musique]
le train touristique des cantons de
l'est empruntent la voie ferrée de mma
est actif depuis par la tragédie de
lac-mégantic sur le même chemin de fer
on est extrêmement touchée de voir ça ça
nous fait mal
depuis le premier jour de sa
cohabitation avec mma leurs feux
d'express efforcé de rouler au tiers de
sa vitesse de croisière en raison du
mauvais état de la voie clara est digne
aulas avait fixé et diyala
c'est un après sks qu'elle a continué se
dégrader moi je comprends pas qu'on
laisse des années des années après avoir
mis une restriction imposée votre
transport canada on essaie tant preuve
115 milliards
satisfaite j'étais enfant
mais pour donald thompson le plus
incompréhensible
reste la décision de transports canada
de laisser mm à conduire ces trains avec
un seul homme
parce que imaginez vous avez un convoi
d'aidé des wagons de 100 tonnes minimes
achats de matières dangereuses et seule
avait cinq six locomotives
c'est quand même une responsabilité
croyants
le record est convaincu que ça diminue
les risques et neymar et pose la
pratique et ses employés dans mène
depuis 2004 une dizaine d'entre eux dans
ce mécanicien de locomotive ont
démissionné pour cette raison vous êtes
sont fatigués et vous traversez des
villes avec un chargement de
marchandises dangereuses
c'est dur si on est deux à bord on peut
s'entraider
j'étais sûr qu'il finirait par y avoir
un accident
la sécurité est un des arguments
invoqués par nma quand elle annonce à
transports canada en 2009 son intention
de réduire ses équipages de ce côté ci
de la frontière
jusqu à lac mégantic
enquête a obtenu les courriels que se
sont échangés mma et transports canada
on y découvre que plusieurs
fonctionnaires ne sont pas favorables au
projet la compagnie n'a pas de données
pour soutenir l'idée que c'est plus
sécuritaire qu' avec deux hommes à bord
mma a démontré qu'elle ne comprend pas
son rôle et ses obligations de sécurité
aux passages à niveau
en plus elle ne semble pas bien
comprendre les exigences requises pour
les dérailleurs
une rencontre est organisée au bureau de
transports canada à montréal
deux représentants de l'association
canadienne des chemins de fer sont
présents ont ce point de sécurité sont à
l'ordre du jour le commentaire d'un
fonctionnaire nous sommes toujours
préoccupés par les infractions répétées
commises par aimé ma on demande à mma de
présenter son projet au maire de nantes
frontenac et lac-mégantic le pdg robert
green wood écrit mais surtout aucune
inquiétude n'a été soulevé dans ces
trois rencontres sur le risque réel ou
potentiel pour la sécurité du public
transports canada décide d'examiner de
plus près la gestion de mma nous avons
fui le constat de cette audi daté avril
2010 aux consultants servières jacques
d'andersen de cette un rapport qui fait
état de lacunes graves
le personnel de cadres n'ont pas la
formation nécessaire et pire encore ne
connaissent pas la description de leur
tâche
nm ans admet ne pas avoir encore
implanté son clan de gestion de sécurité
elle attend que transports canada
l'approuvent depuis sept ans les règles
transmise aux employés ne sont pas à
jour
l'audi révèle aussi des déficiences dans
l'inspection des trains et dans les
tests de freinage pour une compagnie qui
fait autant d'entorses réglementé vais
autant d'attractions donc d'autoriser
d'avoir un seul conducteur à bord de la
cabine s'est renforcé le vice
malgré le rapport accablant et malgré
les réserves de nombreux fonctionnaires
transports canada n'empêche pas et
n'aimant d'entrer en territoire
québécois
avec un seul homme à bord au printemps
nous on transporte des personnes 1 du
monde commence ici c'est pas des boîtes
de papier en plus de subir le mauvais
état de la voie le orford express doit
se soumettrait éléments pour
l'inspection de son matériel roulant un
non sens pour donald thompson lui-même
mécaniciens de locomotive et chefs de
train certifié on s'aperçut quelquefois
que la personne n'avait pas toujours non
seulement les connaissances comment
toutes les composantes fonctionne
composante air de base est donc là on se
posait des questions quelle est la
formation que ces gens là on s'est posé
des questions souvent par précaution il
embauche son propre lecteur pour refaire
les inspections en double et même en
exige par ailleurs qu'il contracte une
assurance responsabilité de 50 millions
de dollars soit qu'on a obtenus et quand
tu es la transition on a appris comme
tout le monde qui avait 25 millions pour
eux et
bon c'est une surprise d'apprendre ça je
me disais à mon but et c'est quand même
quelque chose l'a transporté un convoi
de sept emplois et ils ont 25 millions
donc comment se fait-il
c'est un poids deux mesures la loi sur
le transport des marchandises
dangereuses permet d'imposer un seuil
minimal d'assurance responsabilité aux
compagnies ferroviaires malheureusement
le gouvernement ne l'a jamais fait
une nouvelle qui était descendu ce matin
c'est l'inquiétude caudry beaucoup c'est
pas otages a dit moi j'appelle ça un
apocalypse
ouais et les images sont apocalyptique
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir mettrait
hors de contrôle dans une brusque
hamburg dirige un groupe de chercheurs
un politique alternative
il a vu la catastrophe à la télévision
mais s'est sentie touchée
personnellement une de mes collègues a
perdu trois membres de sa famille dans
l'accident ça m'a vraiment bouleversée
selon cet observateur si la conduite un
seul homme n'est pas la cause directe de
l'accident
elle trahit les capacités de transport
canada à faire passer la sécurité avant
les besoins financiers des entreprises
mm hors tout ce qu'il a fait c'est légal
et c'est de transports canada qui lui a
permis de faire je suis convaincu que
c'est le temps de rééquilibrer le
pouvoir entre les régulateurs et
l'industrie parce que les industries est
trop trop puissant dans cet arrangement
le budget alloué à la sécurité
ferroviaire a rétréci de 20% depuis 2010
bruce campbell estime que les victimes
de lac mégantic en ont payé le prix
imagine le mans qui est aux musiques à
fait il pense que le gouvernement prend
des mesures raisonnables pour les
protéger c'est la fonction du
gouvernement de fonction primordiale du
gouvernement de les protéger c'est pas
c'est pas la fonction du gouvernement de
deux assists et les actionnaires de mm à
l'essor du transport de pétrole brut va
bientôt offrir la chance a aimé ma de
mettre fin ses difficultés financières
mais avant elle veut aller plus loin
encore avec ses équipages réduit et se
prépare à jouer sa deuxième manche
auprès de transports canada
[Musique]
c'est avec soulagement que les gens de
farnham ont vu partir les 84
wagon-citerne rempli de pétrole resté
coincé aux portes de la ville depuis
l'accident les parties j'espère être
parti pour longtemps
on a beau les chasser de la vue les
wagons citernes ne sont pas près de
disparaître
il faudra au moins dix ans pour
renouveler les milliers de vieux
d'autres 111 qui ne répond plus aux
normes
les chaussées pour le manque de
marchandises dangereuses peine pour seul
qu'on a besoin de toute urgence
réjean simard vient de prendre sa
retraite après vingt ans comme
spécialiste des marchandises dangereuses
à transports canada les ressources pour
faire le travail dit il n'ont aucune
commune mesure avec la croissance
vertigineuse du transport du pétrole
tarterêts on parle d'une trentaine
d'inspecteurs de marchandises
dangereuses pour vérifier plus de 40
missions d'inspection au canada alors il
ya des se trouver un chemin plus
inquiétant encore l' expertise que le
ministère a développé au fil des ans est
en train de disparaître dans la vague
des compressions dans l'eau perdue le
spécialiste canadien pour les grosses
terme on est perdu la spécialiste
canadien pour les noms bombes à gaz
c'est un honneur perdu le spécialiste
canadien pour les camions-citernes
cesser les pertes qu'ont eu ces des
percées ce n'est personne clique on
avait là qu'on a perdu
les gens simard était le spécialiste des
plans d'urgence
c'est ovine à qui était destiné le
convoi de lac-mégantic avait eu un tel
plan les secours auraient été plus
rapide à s'organiser
[Musique]
on m'a demandé de l'échelle
il faudra plus de 16 heures avant que
des émulsifiants pour combattre les feux
de pétrole ne soient acheminés ainsi qu
à des pompiers comment se fait-il qu'il
ait fallu attendre ses joueurs pendant
ce temps là ça brûle personnellement je
pense que c'est une lacune de notre
règlement vous avez même plaidé pour
qu'il y en ait pour ce genre de produit
d'un certain moment lorsque je te
reprocher j'ai signalé mais pas trop
qu'on devrait plus le pétrole brut dans
les exigences du plan d'urgence
le manque n'a jamais été comblé en dépit
d' accident szakaly juste une question
de temps avant que ça arrive une ville
comme big antique et même à transporte
déjà des marchandises dangereuses avec
une fiche de sécurité douteuses
quand elle revient voir transports
canada en 2011
les fonctionnaires sont mal à l'aise
quand ils apprennent qu'elle veut
prolonger la conduite un seul homme
jusqu à farnham 200 km plus loin
le syndicat des métallos est réticent
lui aussi lui existe une question qu'on
a mais la rentabilité rentabiliser son
entreprise
richard boudreault était négociateur
pour les métallos pour renouvellement de
leur contrat de travail avec mm
pour nous le plus de responsabilités à
certaines personnes puis en plus on va
pas déjà oui c'est un enjeu majeur lucky
strike qui nous entraînait jusqu'à
devant un conciliateur puis finalement
c'est conciliateur qui disaient qu'ils
ont comme dit que vous pouvez me suivre
ou arrêter ça c'est pour vous que les
transitions c'est ça vous appartient pas
cette fédérale qui va décider
[Musique]
le fédéral n'a pas l'air chaud à l'idée
le bureau régional de transports canada
à montréal prévient qu'il ne trouve pas
la conduite un seul homme tant que mma
ne s'est pas d'évaluation de risques
sérieuse nous considérons que ce
changement majeur aux opérations exposé
l'équipage et les communautés
environnantes à un plus grand risque est
même en répond avoir rencontré toutes
les villes concernées et qu encore une
fois personne n'a exprimé d'inquiétude
le maire d'une de ces villes celles des
femmes affirme n'avoir jamais été
consulté il ignorait que le train était
conduit par un seul homme non ça je ne
savais pas je veux être franc avec vous
je ne savais pas non il aurait fait les
rencontres le avec les maires et tout
terrain quand elle voulait vous rire de
moi madame vomi support vrai là on est
sans jamais rencontrer cantal
[Musique]
les exigences du bureau régional de
transports canada à montréal irrite mma
ils ont recours à n'importe quel
argument pour retarder le processus de
plainte un directeur de la compagnie au
pdg robert green wood celui-ci écrite
aussitôt à la puissante association des
chemins de fer du canada et l'informent
qu'il y à du sable dans l'engrenage il y
avait de tout les côtés là beuglements
l'association a usé de tout son poids
comme l'indiquent le registre des
lobbyistes pour convaincre les décideurs
que les règles entourant le transport
des marchandises dangereuses étaient
suffisantes
entre 2009 et la fin de 2013
les deux grandes compagnies cndp et
l'association des chemins de fer du
canada
en tout les trois ont fait des contacts
avec des bureaucrates et des politiciens
plus que 700 voix l'affirmation que les
règles de sécurité sont suffisantes a
disparu peu après la tragédie
mais en 2011 l'association des chemins
de fer et le pdg de mma sont du même
avis sur la conduite à un seul homme il
semble qu'on soit face à de nouveaux
obstacles de la part de transports
canada le bureau de montréal s'oppose
fermement au projet depuis le début
mais ces décisions sont souvent renversé
par la direction à ottawa laisse moi ça
robert répond un haut placé de
l'association des chemins de fer il
ajoute je vais passer quelques appels
une nouvelle rencontre a lieu entre mma
et transports canada
un fonctionnaire de montréal s'inquiète
m m en a pas d'équipements pour détecter
un train à la dérive
j'aimerais que mes mains nous explique
comment elle peut avoir la rigueur
nécessaire pour conduire ces trains avec
un seul homme quand c'est précisément ce
manque de rigueur qui a mené à nos
inquiétudes ya nos actions ces dernières
années les objections n'y font rien en
mma un plan de la conduite un seul homme
jusqu'à fana
[Musique]
- le premier j'étais con legatt train
toutes les employées que ce soit là
maintenant on sous les ingénieurs ou les
braeckman tout le monde est à comp
c'est trop dangereux au sur la question
l'ipo question renault voit pas en train
de passagers comme seul nom en option le
offre l'express dont la locomotive est
conduite par mm ans a choisi de
maintenir ses effectifs même plus que ça
nous on est toujours chef de train mais
quinzaine de communes si et chefs de
cabine sauce une décision qu'on a prise
dans l'entreprise pour assurer une plus
grande sécurité
malaise aussi chez les métallos c'était
comme si c'est arrangé avec le gars des
vues
jonathon band match eyes parce que nous
on voyait pas que le gouvernement irait
jusqu'à ramener un tel permis à m hamon
au lendemain de l'accident le ministre
denis lebel a défendu la décision de son
ministère
nous ne donnons pas nous d'autorisation
en fonction d'une compagnon d'une autre
il ya des règles générales ils se
doivent de respecter les règles pourtant
mma avait souvent enfreint une règle
importante sans subir la moindre
sanction
c'est la fameuse règle sur
l'immobilisation des trains enquête a
découvert de multiples infractions entre
2004 et 2012 y compris à nantes
là où le convoi de mma a amorcé sa
descente morten inacceptables certains
la règle et là on me dit l'un -
catégoriquement font dire à d'autres on
est tous sens même mieux à ce que change
la même réglementation alors c'est comme
si vous dites toujours aimé main
franchement canada attention je vais
frapper je vais faire mais comme ils
savent que vous l'avez jamais le faire
mais on continue pourquoi se gêner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la règle 112 est au coeur de l'enquêté
des autorités pour déterminer combien de
frein à main le conducteur à appliquer
mais s'il a suivi les instructions
fournies par mma et que nous avons
obtenu ce n'est pas rassurant
elle exige ne ferait à main pour un
convoi de sept longueurs incluant les
frais appliqués aux locomotives
une grave imprudence qui aurait réduit
la force de freinage de 40% ne tente
rien d'accabler ce conducteur de tous
les maux de la terre alors que ce n'est
peut-être que la conséquence de toute
une culture d'entreprise fait de
négligences et de laisser-aller et aussi
d'un manquement grave à sa mission de
transports canada transports canada a
refusé de nous accorder une entrevue
mais nous avons mis la main sur cette
note préparée à l'intention du ministre
on y admet que des pratiques permise par
transports canada dont la conduite un
seul homme ont pu contribuer à
l'accident et amplifier ses conséquences
[Musique]
le froid glacial qui s'est abattue sur
lac mégantic n'efface pas la trace
laissée par lebrazi les employés de mm à
vivre avec le poids de la tragédie on a
été montré beaucoup du doigt mais des
fois le monde me traitait de soir et
comme les gens de lac mégantic
ils peinent à s en remettre j'ai perdu
des membres de ma famille 47 mans pour
quelque chose qui aurait pu être évitée
ces trous il ya deux journées que ça va
bien deux journées que ça va moins bien
j'ai encore des cauchemars des
flashbacks puis je sais que c'est pas de
ma faute
[Musique]
au milieu du centre-ville dévasté on
déplace la dernière citerne ayant
appartenu aux convois de la mort les
inquiète révéleront sans doute une
funeste série d'erreurs et de négligence
mais ce qui a déraillé ce soir là c'est
aussi notre système de surveillance de
l'industrie ferroviaire